人非常奇怪，
姐妹，
我给你讲一个逻辑，
如果有一天你自己把你自己活成了一个快乐的源泉的时候，
他反而会过来粘着你。
我现在跟我老公暂时思想分开，
因为孩子还小，
可是36岁，
我老公是47，
他爸我11岁，
我们有个儿子是11岁，
都是头婚。
我们经济上没有很大的压力，
共同经历了一个建材的生意，
年收入大概在25~30个，
老板的心一直也不错，
孩子爸爸对家里也很好，
也算是春节的爸爸。
我们两个人也都没有不良嗜好，
没有大的矛盾，
也没有什么两亲家庭的干扰，
他们也没有明显的错。
困扰我的原因在于我觉得他这个人对我特别冷漠。
出现这些问题的原因呢，
一是在于我们两个人因为有实际的年龄差，
三观的理念上就会不契合，
再就是两个人相处中，
他是比较冷淡，
不淡多，
就是比较强的一种性格，
两个人的性格就会给彼此带来一些困扰，
之前是有肢体化的反应，
事情呢，
一直是看明的时候，
就是把日子过好啊，
给您推荐了一些电视剧啊，
书啊，
我都会反复看好了很多，
状态已经平衡了很多，
我老公他是那种回避信息验，
然后我说高敏感，
我就跟所有的回避性系列的伴侣一样，
就是从最初。
一个安全型转成的一个消虑性讨论的有两年，
我现在就是状态好很多，
主要的原因在于，
比方说我们两个人在相处的工作中的问题，
他遇到问题只会忍处理，
就不会去解决任何问题，
也不会去缓和和促进两个人的夫妻关系。
我们最近一次有长达一个月的冷战，
他碰到任何的问题他就会逃避，
逃避任何冲突，
面对事情他没有掀桌子的那个观念。
就比方说举个例子，
我们上一次带小孩身餐店里，
我们选座的时候选的是比较好的位置，
我走到那个座位的时候，
我就发现就位算有人，
我就跟那个座位上的那个美女说，
我说美女你好像要看一下你的票，
他说坐错位置了，
他说我们都是乱坐的，
我没有按票的号来，
当时我就想跟他理论这个事情，
就是你应该坐到你的位置，
我应该坐在我的位置，
但是我老公他立马就会把我拽走，
他就算了，
有很小的事情，
有很多事情，
就是他会避免冲突，
我会去解决问题，
时间久了之后，
我就觉得自己有一个家，
但是没有依靠，
很多这种小的事情堆一，
比方说我过生日，
情人节，
大小节日，
他不会有什么礼物啊，
鲜花呀，
或者说一点比较幽默风趣的话，
他都没有这些动作，
反而他对我的话，
他会频繁的去纠错，
比方跟他说。
一点事情分很多次，
没有明确的去表达我的想法和需求，
但是他不会去做，
也不会去花心思，
在只有我们两个人的夫妻关系，
长时间加上我的工作呀，
养育孩子的压力啊，
就会导致我的性格就变得比较急躁焦虑，
然后我现在就对他产生应激反应，
如果他状态很好的跟我说话，
状样还比较好，
如果他脾气不好，
就会我说话，
我就会非常的烦躁，
他就会觉得我脾气不好，
性格不好，
我们两个就是恶性循环，
关系就比较不融洽。
最近一次一个人的冷战是因为故意伏我十几年，
一直是我去让步，
我去促进感情升温，
就我跟你说我去解决，
但第一次就是我不想解决了，
我们就有一个多月的冷静，
下孩子班主任他给我打电话，
就说我们小孩出去看可能状态不太好，
我就随一果跟他吐槽，
我说真的，
我感觉别人带小孩都特别容易，
就是我们带着小孩就这么难，
我他就回了一句，
他说我强自而弱，
孩子有现格的问题，
都是因为你的性格导致的，
我当时就感觉很受伤，
由于我觉得孩子教育成长都是我在受，
我只是随口跟你吐槽，
你可以去安慰我，
但是你们拿一些大道理先来跟我讲，
我今天很难受。
我问你啊，
姐妹，
你今天来找我的目的就是说咱俩聊聊天，
但是你是不想跟他分开的，
对不对？
对一句话问你。
要不今天出门被车撞了，
就是他把你的日子好过呢，
还是他活着你的日子好过，
他活着我好过好，
那这就是答案，
既然只要是他是一个活着的，
最起码咱有一个孩子他爸，
最起码咱有一个壮劳力，
最起码家里面来了歹徒了，
他能够顶一顶，
最起码说家里面有个男人在的话，
咱住在家里心里踏实一点，
这就是他的价值，
就是你对他的价值要从情绪价值转变为实用价值，
就他是个男的，
他是个活的，
他有力量，
他在家里一放，
最起码我不怕流浪汉来敲我的门，
最起码我不怕谁半夜来偷什么东西啊什么的，
有个难的啊，
就心里有这样一个底气在，
最起码孩子出什么事儿了的话，
还有个有商有量的，
就是你从今天开始，
对这个男人的价值不要再倾向于什么情绪价值，
要的是实用价值，
所有的情绪全是向内求，
我怎么让我自己高兴。
其实我特别推荐你去看一个电影，
这个电影的名字叫万箭穿心，
是严丙燕演的，
这部电影当时拍出来的时候票房非常差，
但是这部电影值得我们所有女人都去看，
都去研究，
都去琢磨明白了，
我活着一辈子，
我最想要的东西是什么，
什么东西最重要，
我感觉那个万箭穿心里面那个女主角就是活一辈子什么苦她都吃了，
什么罪他都遭了，
到最后她什么都没有得到，
你可千万别活成那样，
就是从今天开始，
你。
每天早上起来问我自己一个问题，
我老公是活着好还是不好活着好，
他今天是活着的，
感恩，
感谢老天爷，
他还活着，
我从此之后对他没有任何情绪上的索取，
我只要求实用价值，
实用功能，
明白吗？
明白就是不要求他情绪上有回应，
对我只要求他是活着的，
他只要不主动来打我骂我，
拖我的后腿的话，
他活着就好，
好我明白了，
我就需要努力点去骂我一下，
点醒我这些东西我就是心里明白这个道理，
说听的多，
但是我自己身上有行动有点困难，
所以我需要你去点醒我一下，
对，
你今天一定要去看那部电影，
就叫万箭穿心，
她有两个版本，
一个版本是方言的，
一个版本是普通话的，
我感觉我们就直接听那个普通话版本的就挺好的，
然后你看那个电影，
你就做笔记，
你就琢磨一下这个女主，
她一生她得到了个啥，
他图个啥，
我要怎么做才能避免他的命运，
才能避免到最后我啥也没吐槽的命运，
那我只要你要活着，
对家庭负责就可以了，
只要求自己开心，
不寻求他的情感回忆，
对，
就是这个意思，
人非常奇怪，
姐妹，
我给你讲一个逻辑，
如果有一天你自己把你自己活成了一个快乐的源泉的时候，
他反而会过来粘着你，
他离开你非常奇怪，
就是这个逻辑，
我直播间有没有姐妹们？
当你自己就是解开那个扣了，
你自己开了窍了，
你活成一个家庭里面那个快乐的源泉，
所有人靠近你等于靠近快乐，
靠近你等于靠近幸福的时候，
他反而他粘着你，
他到老了，
不走一步，
她跟一步，
她恨不得给你删，
快要带上好的，
我明白了，
丽玉姐，
我这些年能够从一个公路英郁和家你走出来，
全是看你的直播，
看你的书，
太感谢了，
谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜，
你看我直播间好多姐妹，
她就是怎么突然有一天开了窍了之后，
你不再向外求，
不再寄希望于她对你提供情绪价值，
她夸你，
你每天自己向内求，
我怎么做事情让我自己高兴，
我干点啥让我自己高兴，
我跟谁喝杯茶让我高兴，
我跟谁出去打个球让我高兴，
你变成那个快乐和幸福的原点，
周围的人都得围着你，
他真离不开你，
因为他离开你等于离开幸福，
离开你等于离开了快乐。
他为什么要离开你？
记得点赞关注哦。